[Music]
there is a vending machine for every 23
people in Japan
that's the highest vending machine per
capita on the planet
[Music]
after the business card Fiasco I started
to become keenly aware of all the
vending machines that I saw here in
Japan I noticed they arced everywhere
indeed what we're looking at here is a
Japanese institution behind me sits an
entire shop dedicated to chopsticks yes
I'm about to go inside the first thing
you have to know in order to understand
the vending machines is that Japan is an
ageing country the average age here is
46 years old which is almost double the
world average and the fertility rate is
1.4 which means the population is
actually shrinking this is actually a
looming crisis for Japan generally but
one of the effects of it is that the
labor market is very expensive there's a
scarcity of low-skilled labor so instead
of paying a sales clerk to sit and
collect your money when you buy a piece
of gum they just put it in a machine and
automate the whole thing and the same
goes for real estate Japan is one of the
densest countries in the world 93
percent of the population lives in
cities people literally live in
apartments smaller than your SUV so
instead of paying a lot of money for a
store front retailers will just slip a
little machine into an alleyway to save
a lot of money and they can still turn a
really good profit according to one
essay that I read from a Japanese
economist here in Tokyo the bigger
explanation for the vending machines is
a fascination or even an obsession with
automation and robotics everything that
can be automated here is automated when
I go into order like a ramen or
breakfast more often than not I order on
a machine and I give a little ticket to
someone it's an indicative of a broader
cultural trend of wanting to automate
every system you possibly can every taxi
in Tokyo has automated doors that the
driver controls now I don't want to
overstate this there's still a major
appreciation for
handcrafted artisanal goods here in
Japan a good example of this is the
seven-year-old coffee shop I just got
out of where they literally use a
weighted scale to weigh their coffee
beans before grinding them and brewing
them to order to quit on their coffee
they put it into a metal vessel and spin
it around a giant ice cube so yes they
love automation but they're still very
much in touch with handmade so another
thing that totally contributes is this
point egde so much coinage the one big
caveat to the whole automation thing is
that definitely gotten on board with
credit cards yet everything is cash
based and because they you always have
coinage when the highest coin is worth
like five dollars and let's be honest
there's nothing more satisfying than
unloading some of the change in your
pocket into a vending machine for some
yummy treat my personal favorite item is
hot green tea tea comes out wonderfully
warm and you just wonder how you got so
lucky so Japan is an ageing nation with
expensive labor and a love for robots
and too many coins in its pocket
[Music]